[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مفكر وباحث سوداني متخصص في
الدراسات الاسلاميه له العديد من المؤلفات
والدراسات والاجتهادات في الفكر الاسلامي
عمل مع العديد ايضا من المفكرين على راسهم
حسن الترابي يرى ان الاسلام السياسي
استنتدى اغراضه وانتهى وان الديمقراطيه هي
الاداه لتحقيق مفاهيم الحريه والعداله
المفكر والباحث السوداني المعروف المحبوب
عبد السلام في سؤال مباشر سيد المحبوب
حياك الله معي في سؤال مباشر كل عام وانت
بخير
مرحبا بكم كل عام وانتم بخير
اهلا وسهلا فيك خليني ابدا معك من كتابك
الحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه دائره الضوء
وخيوط الظلم هذا الكتابه ثار الكثير من
الجدل الكاتب السوداني عبد الوهاب الافندي
قال ان هذا الكتاب هو بمثابه النعي للحركه
الاسلاميه اكثر من ما هو التاريخ يعني شبه
رسمي لها انت ايضا قلت في تصريح مؤخرا بان
الاسلام السياسي استنفض اغراضه وانتهى هل
فعلا حركه الاسلاميه اولا السودانيه انتهت
بالفعل هل كنت تنعيها في كتابك وهل
الاسلام السياسي انتهى فعليا كما تقول
انا كتبت الكتاب قبل
اكثر من عشره اعوام
وانا ذاك كانت الادب الذي يتحدث من داخل
بيت الحركه الاسلاميه كان صحيحا وكان
محدودا
ولاسيما ان الحركه التي تحدثت عنها كانت
حاكمه لمده عشر سنوات
وكان كثير من قراراتها
وما يظهر منها
يشوبه الغموض بالنسبه لحتى المثقف
والسياسي في السودان وفي خارجه الكتاب كان
محاوله
للتجوال داخل
ذهن السلطه وداخل مطبخها وكيف تحدث
التقلبات داخل
ذهن السلطه وكيف تنتقل
وهذا التطور والتحول الذي رصته
كان بمثابه مؤشر قوي لكثير من الناس ان
هذه الحركه قد وصلت الى طريق مسدود وان
كنت عندما كتبت الكتاب لما كنا اعتقد هذا
الاعتقاد ولكن بعد ان كتبت الكتاب في
المسار المراجعات المستمر وبتامل الحركات
الاسلاميه في العالم كله وليس السودان فقط
انتهيت الى نتيجه ان الاسلام السياسي قد
استنفذ اغراضه بمعنى ان الرؤيا والفكره
والاطروحه قد جربت في مستويات مختلفه بما
فيها مستوى الدوله واثبت انها غير قادره
على الاجابه على اسئله العصر ولذلك لا بد
من نقله جديده وانا دعوت الى القطيع
النفسيه والمعرفيه مع ماضي الحركات
الاسلاميه التي بدات في القرن قبل الماضي
مع الافغاني
والرضا ومحمد عبده والبنا
فهذه التجربه التي مضى عليها اكثر من قرن
لابد ان يقطع معها وان يتجاوز الى الافق
الانساني الذي يتجلى الان في رؤيه
الديمقراطيه وفي حل الاشكال السياسي عبر
الديموقراطيه وتداول السلمي للسلطه
هل تعين الكتاب منع من التداول سيد محبوب
في السودان
لاول مره طبعا كان ممنوعه من التداول صدر
قرار من المجلس القومي للصحافه المطبوعات
التي كانت تهيمن عليه السلطه انذاك سلطه
الانقاذ كما كانت تهيمن على كل المؤسسات
فالكتاب كان بمثابه صدمه كبيره له وهم
سارعوا الى قراءته قبل ان يقراه راي العام
السوداني فمنع رسميا وحاول الناشر
زار هذا المكتب مكتب الذي يمنح تراخيص
دخول الكتب زاره اكثر من عشرين مره وكان
يعد في كل مره بان يصدر قراري لان صدر
القرار بمنعه واعترف الامين العام لذلك
المجلس بان الكتاب قد منع وكان اغلب
السودانيين يهربونه من القاهره شاعت نكته
انذاك ان هنالك شيئان ممنوعان في السودان
هما جهاز كشف الذهب وكتاب المحبوب ولكن
كلاهما يدخل من مطار الخرطوم كيف كانت
الاصداء داخل السودان عن الكتاب
الشعبيه كبيره جدا كما ذكرت لك ان الادب
نعم كانت كبيره جدا خاصه وسط مثقفين اكثر
من الكتاب كتب بلغه يعني صعبه شيء ما على
على عامه الناس ولكن بالنسبه للطبقه
النخبه السياسيه وهي نخبه عريضه في
السودان من قديم
الكتاب اثار ضجه واثار حوار واسع جدا لانه
لاول مره كما قلت الادب كله صحيح ولكن كيف
يصنع القرار داخل اروقه الانقاذ كيف يدار
هذا المطبخ الخلافه السياسي والصراع الذي
كان مكتوما الى الانفجر في المفاصل
الشهيره
انا حاولت ان اكون موضوعيا جدا وان اركز
على تحول الافكار وتطورها اكثر من التركيز
على الاشخاص ولكن طبعا كانت هناك شخصيات
محوريه لعبت ادوار خطيره ادت انحراف
المشروع
وكان لابد من الاشاره اليها فلذلك بس
الكتاب عصب دقيق
ومن شخص كان فعلا داخل هذه الاروقه كان
مراقبا لصيقا
وانا طبعا كاتب لا اقصد اقصد اذا كان
اشخاص معينين داخل ربما هذه الجماعه وداخل
السلطه خاصه انت تحدثت عن اسماء معينه كما
تقول
كان اكثر تركيز على الشخص الذي احتكر
السلطه بالكامل في العامين الاولين
الانقاذ العام الذي كان فيه الترابي في
المعتقل سته اشهر في كوبر السجن المشهور
وسته اشهر في البيت ثم بعد ذلك تعرض لحادث
في كندا فكان هنالك عامين يحكم فيهما
السيد علي عثمان محمد طه حكما مطلقا كان
حاكما مطلقا بالفعل على على الجيش وعلى
الامن وعلى السياسه وعلى الاقتصاد او كان
بمثابه
خميني في تلك الفتره فكان لابد ان يكون
هناك تركيز عليه في في هذا الكتاب
هل تعرضت لمضايقات اثناء او بعد تاليفك
الكتاب من اشخاص او من داخل السلطه سيد
محبوب
هم اتخذوا غير المنع
المادي للكتاب نحن اتخذوا كذلك سياسه
ماكره هي ان كثير من الكتاب الذين
يؤالونهم قد كتبوا مقالات تشير الان
الكتاب فارق وليس في اي مضمون ولا محتوى
سوى دفاع
مجرد عن الترابي وايدان على عثمان فشاه
شاه هذا المفهوم وسطهم وكان اكثر ما
يحرصون على حمايتهم اعضاء الحركه لا سيما
شبابها ولكن كثير منهم جاء الى القاهره
واشترى الكتاب وقراه وقابلني
سرا ونجوى وحدثني ان الكتاب احدى الصدمه
وسط شباب الحركه الذين كانوا يرون ان
قيادتهم هي قياده مقدسه لا تخطي ولكن
الكتاب هذه الشخصيات المقدسه الرفيعه قد
اعادها الى الارض وحولها الى شخصيات عاديه
دون العاديه تتامر
وتبزل مجهود كبير في المكائد وفي المكاسب
الشخصيه وكذلك تمارس الفساد وتمارس
التعذيب وكل هذا كان بمثابه صدمه للقاعده
الشفافيه للحركه طبعا غير اني تحدثت عن
مواضيع مهمه العلاقه بين الجيش والتنظيم
عن التحول في الحكم الاتحادي وتطوره ان
الاقتصاد الاقتصاد الانقاذ من الفلسفه الى
الفوضى فالكتاب كبير في 450 صفحه وفي فصول
كثيره وكان كنت احاول اكون موضوعيا جدا
واكثر ما اركز على الافكار ليس الاشخاص
في تصريح لك قلت قبل قليل بان الاسلام
السياسي كنتيجه يعني لدراستك وبحثك استنفذ
اغراضه وانتهى
لكن عندما تقول انه استنفذ اغراضه وانتهى
انا اريد ان اعرف ما هي هذه الاغراض وهل
كان اداه لقوه خارجيه معينه فرضته في فتره
معينه لاهداف ومصالح
هو الاسلام السياسي كان يزعم انه يريد ان
يؤوب بالحياه العامه الى الدين يريد ان
يؤب بالاقتصاد وبالسياسه وبالجيش والجهاد
وبالتعليم وبالاعلام وحتى بالعلوم البحته
وبمناهج التعليم هذه كانت مزاعم الاسلام
السياسي بانه اريد ان يحكم الناس ليطبق
هذا الاسلام الشمولي ولكن ثبت ان النظريه
خضراء رماديه والتجربه خضراء اذا اردت ان
تحول الاقتصاد
المعاصر الكثيف المعقد العالمي الموصول
بكل الدنيا اذا اردت ان تحوله الى
الاقتصاد اسلامي فهذا زعم كبير
ويحتاج الى دوره حضاريه الذي حدث في الغرب
منذ القرن السادس عشر ان هنالك نهضه
حضاريه كامله كما حدث في القرون الاسلاميه
الاولى لكن مثل بسيط جدا في السودان مثلا
اكثر ما كانوا يهتمون به هو التربيه
واعاده صياغه الانسان السوداني ولكن مناهج
التعليم بالكامل لمده 30 عاما
سلموا منهج التعليم يعني هذه الجماعات
نعم صدقت نعم نعم اغلبهم كانوا معلمين
وانتشروا ولكن في السودان القرار نفسه
القرار السياسي المتحكم في المناهج كان في
يد الحركه الاسلاميه
ولكنها لم تولي التعليم هذا الاهتمام الذي
يستحقه رغم انها تحدثت عن ثوره التعليم
والمفارقه هو ان الجيل الذي خرج بالملايين
واسقط الانقاز هو خريج هذا المنهج فانا
اسميته منهج الشيعي والتقديس كان يهتم بان
يقدس المعلومات في ذهن الطالب بتحفيظه
[موسيقى]
مقدار هائل من الاحاديث والايات ولكن هذا
هذه الشيئيه والتجديد ذابت عند اول اختبار
عند اول مواجهه
صياغه الانسان السوداني
كانت حقيقه عده مواجهات محدوده في في خاصه
في السنوات الاخيره التي ترت انفصال
الجنوب في عام 2012 قامت ثوره محدوده في
يونيو ثم في 2013 كانت هناك اوسع في
سبتمبر ثم انفجر الامر في ديسمبر 2019
انفجر السودان كله ونزل الى الشوارع الى
نسقط الانقاذ اغلب الذين خرجوا خاصه في
البدايه وتحملوا
الوطى الاولى الشديده وطئه الرصاص والعنف
البالغ الذي مارسته الاجهزه الامنيه كانوا
من الشباب من الاجيال الصغيره جدا خريجيه
هذه المدارس وخريجها هذه المناهج وحتى هم
تحدثوا عن ذلك بعض قاده الانقاذ انذاك
تحدثوا اننا ينبغي ان لا نخاف من هذه
المظاهرات للذين خرجوا خريجين هذه المدارس
وهذه مجرد مؤامره شيوعيه ويساريه وبعثيه
تريد ان تظلل هؤلاء الشباب ولكن علينا ان
نصل ونخاط وطبعا هذا كان خطاب متاخر لانه
انت كان بامكانك ان تعيد فعلا صياغه
الانسان السوداني الذي استلمته منذ
المرحله ما قبل التعليم المدرسي منذ رياض
الاطفال ان تستلمته ولكن لم تستطع ان تحول
انا ضربت مثل بالتعليم ولكن
التعليم في الاقتصاد في فصل قصير ونعود
بعده توقف بس عنده فاصل قصير نعود بعده
للحوار في التعليم وفي شؤون اخرى ايضا
متعلقه
بما ذكرته حول حركه الاسلام السياسي بشكل
عام وفي السودان بشكل خاص فاصل قصير
مشاهدينا هنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في سؤال مباشر ضيفي هو
المحبوب عبد السلام المفكر والباحث
السوداني حياك الله معي سيد المحبوب
قلت ايضا في في حديثك بان حركه الاخوان
المسلمين المصريه وهي ام الحركات
الاسلاميه تحولت الى الطائفه
يعني خليني اشاره بسيطه ومختصره ما هي كيف
كانت علاقه حركه الاخوان المسلمين في مصر
كحركه تعتبر هي الام والجامعه الحركات
الاسلاميه وحركه الاسلام الموجوده في في
السودان بشكل مختصر سيد محبوب
العلاقه كانت متوتره جدا لانه فور خروج
السودانيين قاده الحركه من المعتقلات بعد
المصالح الوطنيه في عام 77 طرحت مساله
التنظيم الدولي
وبالمقابل طرح الترابي والقياده السودانيه
انهم لا يؤمنون بتنظيم دولي لحركه اسلاميه
عربيه ولكن يؤمنون بتنسيق عام بين حركات
الاسلام في العالم كلها العربيه
الباكستانيه والافريقيه وفي امريكا وفي
اوروبا وكان هذا بمصابه صدمه كبيره لانه
وفقا للائحه الارشاد عام 1948 ان
التنظيمات الاخوان العربيه هي فروع
للتنظيم الام في مصر فاعتبروا ان ذلك
تمردا من الحركه وخاصه من الترابي يريد ان
يكون مركزا وزعامه ووسمت هذه العلاقه طيله
سنوات
الفتره التي سبقت الانقاذ وبعضا من فتره
الانقاص وقام هنالك تنظيم اخر صغير باسم
الاقوال المسلمين بقياده الشيخ صادق عبد
الله عبد الماجد كان يبذل البيعه لتنظيم
الام في مصر وكان بعضا من التنظيم الدولي
ولكن تنظيم السودان لم يكن ابدا بعضا من
التنظيم الدولي ماذا تقصد بان حركه
الاخوان المسلمين اليوم تحولت الى طائفه
انا عشت في مصر فتره ودرست فيها
وهذه المساله كذلك تناول الكثير من
الباحثين ان الشخص يتخرج من الجامعه فيعمل
اخ المسلم في شركه الجماعه ويصلي في مسجد
الجماعه ويتزوج ابنه رئيس الشعبه واذا
تحرك حتى التاكسي يكون هو تاكسي الجماعه
فكان هنالك مجتمع مصري اخر صغير في حركه
الاخوان وهذه سمه الطائفه التي بدات منذ
مرحله مبكره اظن انه منذ ايام البنا منذ
ان كان لهم مدارس خاصه
ومعاهد خاصه للنساء وكانت له مستشفيات
خاصه وشركات خاصه وجيش خاص طبعا حار في
فلسطين فمنذ ذلك الوقت
نعم نعم هي حركه كبيره ولكنها كذلك تقيم
فاصل بينها وبين المجتمع المصري وهذا ادى
الى المواجهه التي حدثت مؤخرا وهذا ما شرط
اليه انا في احد المقالات التي كتبتها قبل
اربع ايام من التحول الذي قاده الرئيس
السيسي
مش يعني البعض مثلا يقول انه الحكم بهذا
الشكل هو تسطيح يعني مثلا الكاتب بكر فيصل
يقول ان جراه الاستاذ المحبوب في اعلان
رايه حول مستقبل تيار الاسلام السياسي يجب
ان يسحبها جهد فكري معمق يهدف لتفكيك
الافكار الاساسيه التي انطلقت منها جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وتاسيس كتابات ناقده
للرسائل وخطب وكتابات المرشد المؤسس بجانب
افكار سيد قطب ومحمد قطب والترابي وغيرهم
حتى الان يعني الى اي مدى هناك بالفعل
اهميه لتفكيك هذه البنيه الفكريه لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين بشكل عام وجماعه الاسلام
السياسي يعني جماعه الاسلام السياسي بشكل
عام اليوم
والامانه تقتضي ان نقول انهم ما زالوا
مؤثرين على قطاعات واسعه وما ذكره الاستاذ
بابكر فيصل صحيح بنسبه كبيره جدا المفاهيم
الرئيسيه مثلا مفهوم الشمول هل يمكن
للاسلام فعلا ان يكون الشاملا بهذا المعنى
ومفهوم الحكم هذا الحكم الذي ورد في
القران يعني الحكم بالمعنى المعاصر هل
توجد دوله اسلاميه في الاسلام بهذا المعنى
المعاصر ما هي الشريعه التي تعنيها هل
الاحكام التي جاءت في الايات القرانيه
وطبقت في عهد النبي وبعده قليلا هل هي
الاحكام التي يمكن ان تسود الان هذه
المفاهيم فعلا تحتاج ان تفكك انا قرات قبل
مده كتاب جيد جدا كتبه احد اساتذه الفلسفه
والاستاذ فتح الرحمن التوم اسمه
كولونياليه الاسلام السياسي بذل مجهود
كبير في تفكيك هذه المفاهيم انا حتى الان
مازلت اشتغل على تاريخ الحركه اشتغل في
الجزء الثالث من الكتاب وسميه ت في
المقالات ولكن بعد ان افرق من هذه المساله
ساعمد فورا الى مناقشه اصول هذه الافكار
التي تبناها الاسلام السياسي وهي ليست
خاصه فقط بالاسلام السياسي ولكنها سائده
في كل المعاهد التقليديه التي تخرج كل عام
الاف المخرجين ويؤثرون هذا الاتحاد الواسع
كانت الحركه في السودان منوطه به مثلا
عندما ذهبوا الى مفاوضات السلام مع الجنوب
لم يستطيعوا ان يصلوا الاتحاد يستثني فقط
العاصمه من تطبيق قوانين الشريعه وانتهى
الامر فصل ربع السودان جنوب السودان اصبح
دوله مستقله وكعب وخيل والعقده كانت
بقوانين الحدود رغم انها لا تطبق المفارقه
انها لا تطبق غير التعليم كنت ساضرب مثل
بالاقتصاد طيب كان هنالك تمويل لسد بني
تفضل اليوم ايش وضع وش وضع حركه الحركات
الاسلاميه انت تقول مثلا بان هذه الحركه
الاسلاميه تخطط لنفسها عبر مراحل مرحله
كمون ثم مرحله ظهور ثم مرحله التمكين
اليوم في اي مرحله يعني واذا قلنا بانه
انت تقول بانها استنفذت اغراضها وانتهت
يعني بان انتهت كل هذه المراحل اختفت
امنهم بالفعل اليوم ما زالوا او عادوا الى
مره اخرى الى مرحله الكمون وصولا بعد ذلك
الى الظهور ثم التمكين
وطبعا انت عملت في المجتمع لخمسه عقود
لخمسين عاما لنصف قرن ثم عملت في الدوله
لثلاثه عقود لثلاثين عاما فهذه تجربه
مكتمله انت جربت هذه الشعارات وهذه
الافكار في المجتمع وجربتها في الدوله
وانتهت الى بوار الى خيبه وعندئذ اي حركه
انسانيه تعيد النظر بعمق وبتجرد كامل
لترصد اخطائها ثم لتنفذ الى رؤيه جديده
وهذه المرحله التي انا دعوت الى ان تكون
هي مرحله قطيعه نفسيه ومعرفيه لانه قلت ان
هذا التيار تاسس قبل اكثر من قرن مع مع
الافغان تيار اسلام السياسي لانه افغاني
تلميذه محمد عبده محمد عبده لميزو رشيد
رضا ورشيد رضا تلميذه البنا هذه حركه
الاحياء التي بدات منذ ذلك الوقت في تونس
حدث اجتهاد جيد لا باس به حاول ان يفصل
الدعوي عن السياسي ولم يكن كافيا لانه اي
انسان يريد ان يتصدى لتحويل المجتمع الى
مجتمع اسلامي عليه ان يجيب على اسئله
المناهج الحديثه التي بحثت في القران
وبحثت في الحديث وبحثت في الحاله الحضاريه
كلها منذ مالك بالنبي انه هنالك حاله
حضاريه انا كنت اريد ان اشير الى مثل بسيط
انهم ارادوا ان يمولوا سد مروي ولكن
القروض كانت ربويه فعندما او تصوروا انها
الربويه بالمعنى الربا في مكه والمدينه
فذهبوا الى مجمع الفقه الاسلامي وقال ان
هذا حرام وكانوا يريدون ان يبنوا باي ما
طريقه فعقدوا مؤتمر اقتصادي الذين قدموا
اوراق في المؤتمر قالوا ان هذا كان اصعب
شيء عليهم انه يريدون هذه القروض الدوليه
واسهل شيء كان عليهم ان يقارنوا بين الربا
واحكامه التي كانت تتطور والقران ينزل
وبين الاقتصاد السياسي
والمعاصله الكثيف فلم يستطيع ان يقوموا
بهذه الاجتهادات لانهم لم يكملوا مراحل
القطيعه المعرفيه والنفسيه مع تاريخ الفقه
الاسلامي ومع ماضي الاسلام السياسي مازال
السوداني اليوم يعاني من انقسام سياسي
وخلاف كبير ايضا بين النخب المدنيه
والعسكريه ولا احد يعرف بالفعل الى اين
يتجه السودان تم تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق
السياسي النهائي اكثر من مره
حماتي يعني في موضوع الدمج بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش كان له تصريح ملفت بانه
طالب بالتطهير الجيش من انصار
البشير الى اين اتجه السودان برايك وهل
يمكن ان ينجح اي اتفاق سياسي بين قوه
مدنيه وقوه عسكريه في السودان تحديدا
السودان له التجارب طويله في الانتقال
يعني بعد الاستقلال كان هنالك انتقال بعد
ثوره اكتوبر كان هنالك انتقال كان هنالك
انتقال طويل بعد 2005 بعد اتفاقيه السلام
الشامل
ولذلك هذه التجارب كان ينبغي ان لا تهدر
من سوء الحظ انه كثير من رموز السياسيه
والفكريه التي كانت تقود الاحزاب وتقود
المعارضه وبعضهم كان حتى في السلطه من
قاده الحركه الاسلاميه كانوا يمثلون
مستودع للحكمه ولكن مع التغيير غالي في
هذه الشخصيات غابت بالموتى الطبيعي اغلبهم
وبعضهم بالتقدم العمر
فتصدت للقياده بعد الثوره اجيال شابه
عندها تجارب محدوده ولذلك انا دعوت اول ما
دعوت انه الثورات كلها تحتاج الى قيمه
اسمها التسامح السودان يحتاج الى مصالحه
ضخمه مصالحه كتل ليس فقط بين الدعم السريع
والجيش ولكن اقاليم باكملها في في الحرب
الاهليه
غاليهم اهملت منذ منذ البدايه الان هنالك
جدل عن ادماج الحركات الجيوش الدعم السريع
في الجيش وهذه تجربه في العالم كله موجوده
يعني وفيها حلول وافكار ورؤى وتفاصيل فنيه
يمكن ان نصل الى حل ولكن
البعض اللي هي ان كيف يمكن ان نجد صيقه
نحدد بها كيف يحكم السودان هذا الخلاف منذ
الاستقلال ما زال قائما نريد ان نمضي
الانتخابات ولكن ليس لنا احزاب تاسست على
الديمقراطيه يمكن ان تخوض شرط اساسي من
التحول الديمقراطي يمكن ان يخرج العسكريون
من السلطه سيد محبوب امنا كذب كذبه ابريل
كما يرى الكثير مدى لا يمكن ان يحدث ابدا
هل يمكن ان يخرج العسكر من السلطه في
السودان
والله هذا يطرح كشعار ولكن واضح ان
المؤسسه العسكريه في السودان لها خبره
سياسيه ضخمه وراكم التجارب وهم يدرسون
التكتيك والمناوره ولذلك يريدون التدخل في
العمل السياسي طيله عهد الانقاذ كانت كل
مره اتصل فيها المفاوضات السلام مع الحركه
الشعبيه الى مرحله تسبق التوقيع ينهار
لانه الجيش يتحرك ويحتل مدينه فهو غارق في
السياسه متعمق فيها يجيد اللعب فيها باكثر
مما يجيد المدنيون فلذلك لن يخرج بهذه
السهوله هي صيقه المصالحه التي كان يسميها
الاستاذ منصور خالد العوده الى منصه
التاسيس تشمل حتى نظريه امن قومي للبلاد
واذا كانت نظريه امن قومي سيكون هنالك
عقيده عسكريه متفق عليها هنالك ينبغي ان
يقوم مؤتمر للنظام الحكم يحدد ان السودان
يحكم فيدراليا الفيدراليه لها شرطين لابد
منهما هما الجيش الواحد والديمقراطيه
فلذلك الجهد الفكري
والرؤيه هي مهمه نحن نحتاج الان الى افكار
ونحتاج الى قدر هائل جدا من
التسامحين
في السودان انت متفائل ولا لا والله
بوصف يعني
مفكر سياسي ينبغي ان ابذل افكار تساعد على
التفاؤل انا قلت ان هنالك تجارب ولكن
حقيقه الحده القائمه الان في الساحه
السياسيه بين اطرافها المختلفه والخلافه
العسكري يجعل الانسان اقرب للتشاؤم منه
الى التفاؤل واضح شكرا جزيلا لك المحبوب
عبد السلام المفكر والباحث السوداني كان
ضيفي في هذه الحلقه شكرا لك سيد محبوب
عفوا نهايه هذه الحلقه من سؤال مباشر
دائما يمكنكم متابعتنا على تويتر فيسبوك
يوتيوب ومشاهده هذه الحلقه والاستماع
اليها على شاهد وعلى العربيه
[موسيقى]